the next award is a very special one I'd
like a very special person to present it
miss Ginger Rogers
early this morning the Academy Board of
Governors got in touch with me and asked
if I'd make this next presentation yes a
thousand times yes
you'll see why when I read this citation
it says to Fred Astaire for the our
history that has brought unique delight
to picture audiences and has raised the
standards of all musical pictures in
appreciation also of his contributions
to techniques vital to the production of
this type of film under I think it's a
wonderful citation but I don't think any
citation completely please the millions
of people who have watched Fred Astaire
perform they would want that citation to
mention some song he did some tricky
step on a terrace some sly and satin
descent down a staircase and they'd be
right because in all his years of
dancing I don't think Fred Astaire ever
made a movement that did not contain a
hint of high art he not only dignified
dancing as far as I'm concerned he
invented it about the award is a pretty
exciting moment for me too in fact I'm
so excited I could do handspring down
Hollywood Boulevard not sure that many
people here to feel the same way also
I'm sure they want to hear from Fred
Astaire he's not in Hollywood tonight
this special award caught him off face
however he was reached in New York this
noon and right now is supposed to be at
the other end of a special Hollywood New
York Circle
can you hear it spread and you hear it
through a New York Fred Astaire and the
music Fred can you hear that - yes
indeed I can ginger and of course I just
don't know what to say it's it's
wonderful I'm so thrilled I'm ready to
do hand Springs myself down Madison
Avenue and very proud and very grateful
and as for you ginger
you've been much too gracious remember
I've had a partner thanks Fred but
that's not what it says here on the
Oscar
it says in big letters to fred astaire
for goodness sake
don't don't let anything it happened to
it will ya 31 I heard George Murphy on
the show if he's still in the house
would you ask first please accept the
award for me thanks ginger
and god bless you all